she talks a big game on twitter but when
it comes to actually getting stuff done
new york democrat alexandria
ocasio-cortez is coming up short
a new nonpartisan study says aoc was
among the least effective members of the
last congress
introducing 21 bills that went nowhere i
hate bills that go nowhere
all right i'm gonna say something
lawrence that i don't
i think this study is bogus it's like
they're measuring the amount
of blood in a in a sponge it's like
she is probably the most effective
politician
on the on the pla it has nothing to do
with bills anymore does it
yes these people are dumb and this is
why we continue to lose
um look aoc the congress is a
representation
of the current uh population right aoc
is not after the current population
she's after your kids and your grandkids
and she's very effective at it
and the amount of people in the
progressive caucus that exists
now because of her going around the
country to rally them
oh she's been quite effective and you
should be afraid juan you know who she
reminds me of an effective twitter game
but very little uh political i guess
acumen a man known as donald trump
she is the democrat donald trump and
she's going to win
yeah daily wow
i think you gave her a big promotion
there i don't know if she'll ever be
president but
we'll see i mean i think lawrence is
exactly right i think you have to
think about the measure in terms of
legislation she's not as effective as
some people who were in her incoming
class i'm thinking of abigail spanberger
from virginia lauren underwood from
illinois lisa slotkin of michigan they
all have higher scores
but when you stop and think about it
could be that we have an antiquated
measure of what
impact means because twitter does have
impact in terms of public opinion
yeah i mean dana she got
she didn't get any bills passed but she
got amazon out of new york and that cost
new york thousands of jobs
yeah so i mean she doesn't need to pass
a bill consequential
but i do think that actually this i
think that she should assign her staff
to do a better job of helping her get
some things passed
you know just basically have some solid
base hits so she can continue doing what
she's doing that's what staff is for
they should help you on that front
but also this isn't her fault this is
nancy pelosi's fault
think of all the things that were held
up so that president trump wouldn't have
a win
including covet relief so you can't
really pass bills if
nancy pelosi is preventing you from
doing so katie what do you what do you
make of her i mean
at one hey on one hand she doesn't pass
a bill but she's pushing the party
she's pushing the party in the direction
she desires
right or no she's about to pass she's
about okay she
introduced the green new deal yeah then
kamala harris in the senate
co-sponsored it it's about to get passed
as
joe biden's infrastructure plan in some
way or form
so she may not have her name on the
legislation but she has pushed the party
to the left and she is a highly
effective activist and she's going after
democrats in their primaries to continue
pushing
the party to the left so don't
underestimate her she's not stupid
it's going to be really crazy when i run
up against her for president in 2028
well your show can she doesn't have her
own show you gotta do instagram live
greg